[Music]
name shaming news name shame me - Ivana
bar far bartender it hurt a lot when
you're like in third grade makes you
want to cry it's funny kid it's like
everything hurts
yeah it's the end of the world it's
almost like someone say hey you
[ __ ] [ __ ] but it was more like
hey bartender it's a cool name
hey bar your parents are divorced I'm a
gabion and then far far far far said of
like your dad is in love with you I
think that she really is so creative
like immediately they heard your name
it's like somebody was like somebody
decided it it's like Bart fart we're
gonna call him barf are all right this
was submitted by Joe alien fanboy right
Joe Mallya jamali okay I have a country
called Joe Mallya Jesus Southwest
Airlines get just one Southwest airline
apologizes after an employee laughs at a
passenger's name put that out there like
you know if it's like Richard
cunnilingus like holidays yeah I'll get
tears because their name will be dick
Connolly yeah kind of if you get
offended that your name is that in
someone laughs at it like you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] like who cares you don't have a
sense of humor yes if you heard that for
the first time right
and now I mean after like four years and
you hear bark fart you just like uh fire
fire here we go everybody but it's like
that's ridiculous just people like
trying to get attention the mom is her
fault name your kid a dumbass name is a
city that's how it's pronounced AB city
a city AB City right we should call
child services that's what should have
what's it happen [ __ ] might as well
call her alphabet yeah I would crack the
[ __ ] up if I saw that that looks
ridiculous John Wayne Airport in Orange
County
oh well there you go and so yeah the
agent was just laughing so usually what
they do
you're a boarding yeah and then they
give you the yes she kept it the agent
actually kept it and so she was just
laughing and like telling her co-workers
and then in front of them in front of
them something that's kind of rude
behind their back no way way way way it
depends on the last thing if my top of
that haha that's great you know if
they're like this I mean if it was like
that thing here now boarding the stupid
ass of course there why I'm not
surprising the fact is that the whole
situation I would have been like efg
boarding there yeah
we would abuse in alphabetical order
after your first the gate agent started
mocking my child's name laughing
pointing at me and my daughter and
talking to other employees so I turned
around and just said like hey I can hear
you so if I can hear you my daughter Jen
- like I'd appreciate it you just stop I
mean that's kind of like you asking for
it once you when you make a unique or
weird name like do you expect your water
go well that's next level man that's so
[ __ ] cool stupid stupid but as it if
it's your job to to provide customer
service then that's your [ __ ] job
you don't mean like if you're now
representing a company like if I own
Southwest Airlines and one of my staff
did that I'm like well what the [ __ ]
that's our professionals yeah but I
would be like if my boss would come over
and I'd be like I mean do you see the
name Matlin don't laugh it down she
named her ABCDE yeah if I was selfless I
would I would [ __ ] sue her dude it's
the other way around was putting me
through that [ __ ] yeah
we're all average because blood the girl
was five years old [ __ ] was I'm still
sticking to my guns I don't give up she
ended up posting on social media and
that's when people found the mom on
social media because there were certain
identifying markers that people were you
were to search around they started
making fun of her and like your daughter
and all this stuff well I really make it
fun of the mom I mean I feel bad for the
daughter like [ __ ] this mom this mama
that was that was stupid that is like so
stupid like how selfish a name that is
yep for the mom to be like oh here's
what we're gonna do this is gonna be
great I'm an English teacher so I'm
gonna name my
ABCD you know it's like that's such a
status reaction she wanted so now she's
like what am I supposed to say that name
oh wow how original like original is not
always good exactly that [ __ ] should be
in the box [ __ ] lazy lazy smug you
just took the first part of the alphabet
you [ __ ] lazy [ __ ] and then if you
have a name but you have to explain how
to say it every single time
say my name is Eric right Eri Kay like
I'd be like I wanted to change my
spelling to like AI r e cubed I get it
when you talk about a five-year-old kid
I guess the tough of the month it sucks
that like this five-year-old has to go
through this but the mom should take
some responsibility - yeah that's gonna
be funny for a long [ __ ] time yeah
this is only the beginning in a day of
social media it's only the beginning I
mean it's not like an absentee is a
great name either like that a half city
that literally just sounds like a
malignant tumor on her [ __ ] ovary
like that's what that sounds like to me
AB City is that one of those like
new-age names like yeah no this is like
one Gwyneth Paltrow calling her kid like
River or Apple or some dumb [ __ ] like
that
doesn't make any sense River will make
sure Tyco beats his ass like River
Phoenix
yeah that's pretty stupid actor unless
you're gonna be a musician or a hooker I
don't want to get any of that [ __ ] yeah
yeah sounds like a strippers name it's a
guy's name exactly well with the name
Phoenix I think that's what makes it
cool yeah if it's like River Kaka
walking feet see Phoenix that's what
makes it cool yeah but that's like when
you have like a family that they decided
to name their kids weird [ __ ] yeah or
their Native American like river bowl or
some [ __ ] like that well that fits it
fits the person that you're looking at
you're like it's like mr. Wynn will let
me
I think you're still like you know it's
a guy I it's like if your name is Peter
Lee right that you find out that that
Peters just like the name you give white
people so they understand you know but
every like I know a lot of it like Asian
I still work at an Asian school you know
and it must be like you know you find
out their real name can be pronounce it
yeah so they just go I'm gonna get this
stuff it just call me Rachel be my
computer right so this girl this girl's
gonna have to be called something she
can't even have a nickname yeah yeah
sure Benjamin people y'all been alright
whatever they kidding what are your
short they go call this [ __ ] a just go
back to that kid is not gonna appreciate
this name when she's 17 you know she's
gonna be 17 she's gonna be 67 one day -
oh my god I hate my well thank god she's
cute imagine yeah that's true you can't
be ugly with a dumb name what a dumb
name it just it really comes out if
you're ugly and her name is also ugly
such a weird thing dude for the parent
to name that child a very odd name that
people will question and definitely
laugh at and then be mad that somebody
laughed at it that's what I'm saying so
this is like annoying to me yeah it's
like but it's like it's not like she has
like the Asian person who excuse where
you named your kid [ __ ] bit what about
my fault that's just what it is so it
wasn't my fault
you know I didn't want to have you what
if she has a boring ass name she's like
[ __ ] I hate my boring ass name what's
the mom's name no there's no such thing
like like
like a Kelly yeah but you're like ice -
sorry but like she's just like [ __ ] I
want some I'm like I don't know any
names start at neutral yeah and it gets
doper yeah I don't think anyone goes
Clementine like that's some [ __ ] like
that's some old-timey cool it's but
that's the kind of thing that exactly no
matter what your name is
no one gets called unless you have like
a two syllable name you have something
you know small no one's gonna call
somebody Clementine for their whole life
they're gonna be clam they're gonna be
time they're gonna be you know see
whatever like maybe their middle name is
like you know whatever they're gonna
because CJ they're gonna be like so if
that's just what happens three syllables
is way too long nobody's doing that so
that's what I call you Gio
yeah you don't say joseline they say Jo
they don't say Tiffany they say TIFF
yeah yeah that's so true clementines a
terrible name gonna be horrible anyone
that names their kid that I thought they
would have a really good sensing thing
it sounds like a ghost of a woman that
died in the 90s same where's your sense
of humor it's like if you weren't you
laugh and when you wrote ABC yeah like
she was she took her so that serious
yeah like [ __ ] you you deserve
everything you get in right now yeah I
told you stick to your guns
that's all so we should call child
services and get the I can't take that
away your now Julie [ __ ] and they were
saying that the employee violated the
golden rule of treating every individual
I know they should they're both wrong
with self they're both wrong this mom is
wrong and an employee is well hey you
know you don't do it like that if you're
gonna laugh you just you just kind of go
you know it's like you know
and you like then later you're in a you
in the [ __ ] it southwest of the
lunchroom like look at this you have a
dumbass name wall and that's where that
goes but yet you shouldn't do that
they're both wrong also keep in mind the
Southwest uniform is khaki shorts and
running shoes too oh that's right
they're not like in tuxedos or suits so
they're a pretty casual airline yeah so
like then laughing it's like that's part
of their more [ __ ] up is how she
posted that [ __ ] online like cuz then
yeah it's the full name all that stuff
people get blackout the gas filter at
least I bet you they did they people
always add filters to words cuz you can
easy go you can go on Southwest put the
confirmation number fine you can find
out stuff about so that was what I'm
saying is like what the wrongness of
what that person did is has nothing that
has nothing to do with or take away from
how stupid that name is yeah I mean it
doesn't mean like you can that's what
we're saying right now there's being
unprofessional and then being the idiot
mom yeah they're both wrong yep
[Music]